if you and i just complain about the
republicans didn't do this and the
democrats did do this and wokism in
schools and gender theory and but we
don't actually start building new
institutions
at the end of the day we're gonna go
nuts and by the way that's why a lot of
the talking heads that you see over the
years they get progressively crazier
because if you're just screaming about
stuff but not changing stuff you're
going to be crazy and since you are
hosting my show i will say something
nice about the the fine folks at the
daily wire look you guys are doing the
same freaking thing what you guys did
with jeremy's razors as a an attack
instead of just taking instead of just
being attacked you said no we will
attack harry's they make up this
nonsense it had to do with your tweet
you guys poured i think millions of
dollars into an incredible campaign
you're now selling your own raisers
you're launching a hundred million
dollar campaign for for daily wire kids
that's very much in line with the ideas
of the book politicians are not here to
save us you but you either better figure
out a way to save yourself or you better
find some people
who can help you save yourself together
hello everybody and welcome to the
reuben report i am not dave rubin i have
sort of quaffed and sprayed hair i am
wearing a tailored blazer but i am not
dave rubin i am michael knowles my guest
on today's episode of the reuben report
is
dave rubin dave rubin a new york times
bestselling author and the author of the
new book
don't burn this country dave thank you
so much for coming on your show
michael thank you so much for having me
on my show and before i say anything
else
does it hurt that you have to refer to
me as new york times best-selling author
because they did not put you on the list
now your book sold like 10 times what
technically should have put you on the
list but they felt they could stick it
to you for some reason they didn't stick
it to me maybe they're going to stick it
to me with this one yeah but how does
that feel to you i mean we all know that
the new york times is complete nonsense
and bunk and propaganda and everything
else but nonetheless as someone hosting
someone else's show and having to say
that
i am very much a non-new york times
best-selling author and if for a while
we were all joking and you would say you
wear this as a badge of pride because
the new york times we all know they're
bunk the new york times bestseller list
like all the rest of their newspaper is
an editorial product there was actually
a court decision about this so they
really can just pull you off the list no
matter how many copies you sell so that
that's one side of it but on the other
side and this actually gets to what you
talk about in the book
it does matter the fact that the radical
left controls all of these institutions
will determine
where your book gets placed in the
bookstores it will determine if it goes
on classroom curricula it will determine
how it's talked about how it's reviewed
it it really matters and we're now just
talking about one small subset of just
one institution on the left this is true
of all of the left-wing institutions so
there's a lot i want to talk about in
your book but first because i'm hosting
the show this is my show today thank you
very much i want to talk about my
favorite part of the book which actually
comes in the middle
and it's you know in the book uh it's a
you know a sort of natural follow-up to
don't burn this book your your first
book and it talks about all sorts of
ideas and different parts of philosophy
libertarian philosophy conservative
philosophy but what i love is in the
middle
you don't just talk about ideas you talk
about
doing something you talk about not just
how we're going to tweak this policy how
we're going to tweak this you actually
built something you yourself you dave
rubin built something called locals
locals now affiliated with rumble which
is
which is a separate conservative or at
least non-woke institution
yeah non-woke institution that's really
all it is i wouldn't say it's
conservative or libertarian or
progressive or democrat or republican or
anything else we basically just wanted
to be a neutral platform and you know
for all the years you know knowles you
and i have been having these chats on
each other's shows regardless of who's
hosting what for a couple years now and
and even before i knew you you know i
was having all of these
talks with all of these people and we
were talking about free speech and we're
being censored on these platforms we
know about de-boosting and shadow
banning and all of these other orwellian
terms but nobody's doing anything about
it and it really started hitting me it
was like man
the cavalry ain't coming there's nobody
coming to save us we have to save
ourselves and you know it's kind of
funny now four years after having
created locals and since we've merged
with rumble and my idea with locals of
course was hey i just need a digital
home i need a place where i own my video
i own my audio i own the user data so
that if i ever want to leave locals not
that i would want to leave i created it
and by the way i think only one creator
out of our tens of thousands has ever
left and it had nothing to do with
locals
but i thought let me create this thing
and then see if other people want it too
so we really created it for me first and
then we realized oh wow we've got we've
actually got a business here so this is
this is pretty great because otherwise
just talking about the stuff and this is
an ironic position i suppose for two
guys that talk for a living um you know
at some point it starts making you crazy
right if you and i just complain about
the republicans didn't do this and the
democrats did do this and wokism in
schools and gender theory and but we
don't actually start building new
institutions
at the end of the day we're gonna go
nuts and by the way that's why a lot of
the talking heads that you see over the
years they get progressively crazier
because if you're just screaming about
stuff but not changing stuff you're
going to be crazy and since uh you are
hosting my show i will say something
nice about the the fine folks at the
daily wire look you guys are doing the
same freaking thing what you guys did
with jeremy's razors as a an attack
instead of just taking instead of just
being attacked you said no we will
attack harry's they make up this
nonsense it had to do with your tweet
you guys poured i think millions of
dollars into an incredible campaign
you're now selling your own raisers
you're launching a hundred million
dollar campaign for for daily wire kids
that's very much in line with the ideas
of the book politicians are not here to
save us you but you either better figure
out a way to save yourself or you better
find some people
who can help you save yourself together
not not as a collective but really as a
community not as just oh i'm a cog in a
machine but as oh i have shared values
with these people
let's build some things that's why i
created locals that's why we merged with
rumble that's why we do stuff together
and and that's what people are looking
for they're not looking for us to just
bicker over
marginal tax rates or or even the more
existential stuff they're not just
watching us to have the endless debate
about abortion which of course we can do
and we've done before they want answers
that that's what i'm interested in
otherwise knows we're gonna don't you
feel that like we would just don't you
feel it if you just do this every day
you just talk about this stuff every day
but you don't do anything what's gonna
stop you from just being a complete
talking head screaming lunatic and
there's plenty of those they're all on
msnbc that's right this is something
that's really refreshing about the book
but more importantly it's refreshing
about what
is happening right now what you're doing
with locals what we've done with
jeremy's razors and now dw kids i we're
not going to take our kids to disney
world we're going to take them to wire
world whenever i shouldn't even say that
because you know jeremy's going to go
dump 50 million dollars into that the
minute even here's the idea
there is
this issue on the right and we're all
guilty of it
on the right on the left you can take a
room of a hundred leftists maybe they
have different interests and different
points of view
you can get them on board with something
you can get them to work in concert i
mean that's what we're seeing with the
corporations and the big tech platforms
and the government and the media and the
schools they all get on the same page no
matter what their slight disagreements
might be
when you get into a room full of right
wingers you get if it's 100
right-wingers you're going to get a
hundred different opinions and they're
going to fight tooth and nail over every
issue and a lot of those debates really
do matter a lot of those debates are
really
important
but they paralyze you they stop you from
doing anything and so i'm just so
happy to see okay while we're figuring
out whether it's marginal tax rates or
it's life and death while we're doing
that how about we build up some
institutions that will even permit us
to have that discussion well you know
the thing is michael you know the joke
it's like if you go to a libertarian
conference you know in essence you're
just going to have you know 15 opinions
you're going to have 10 people at the
table 15 opinions on whether you should
have driver licenses or not and then no
one ever accomplishes anything right so
but there's a reason there's a
fundamental reason that does happen with
people on the right and it doesn't
happen with people on the left and it
gets to sort of what i just hinted at
the difference between
the collective and a community they love
the collective that you know we're just
pieces of the machine all of us and
we're just completely interchangeable
and actually
whether you're black or gay or lesbian
or
blind or whatever else that matters more
than whatever your
whatever remaining individual thought
you have
now on the right what you want to do is
if you believe in the individual first
that you michael knowles believe it or
not are capable of logical
thoughtful reasoned thinking you have
some sense of how you can live your life
and that the system should just exist to
allow you to flourish and then hopefully
after you've figured out some stuff for
yourself
maybe you meet a gal that you like and
you start having kids and then maybe you
move to a community that some of the
people there are somewhat in line with
what uh you believe and then you can
flourish and build businesses up that's
the bottom up approach they like the
other approach which is there's a
machine now fit into the machine and i
get why that's that's attractive to
young people that in many ways is what
we're fighting that's kind of what the
book is about we're fighting something
that is much bigger than us because it's
about the human condition people just
want to fit in and if the last two years
of covid taught us anything they will
give up almost everything that is good
and true in the name of fitting in
that's what i want to fight that that's
why the word dystopia is in the subtitle
because
this is a dystopia now we are in a
futuristic movie what happens in every
futuristic movie big government
controlling speech people are afraid to
talk to each other people are locked in
their houses there's a pandemic
overreaching government it's like the
pieces are all here we just need
schwarzenegger to come in and you know
defend the three boobed woman
right right that poor three boobed woman
we've got to protect her won't somebody
please think i remember they shoot her
right up close remember the guy just
yeah
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell